I'm Josie and I'm an astrophysicist
the thing that detected gravitational
waves is made of lasers that's not big
green huge lasers they've got massive
lasers the Einstein telescope with like
ten kilometer lasers gonna be huge
things I was long or wide not long that
would be
whoa do you people have raves with these
jabra bang you could have a great rave
in the ditch call it radio raves yeah
yeah yeah they could the pressure on
Neptune is so high that it could rain
diamonds I'm trying to remember just how
big the black hole is at the center of
our galaxy these three double decker
buses laid end-to-end at least that it's
like ten to the nine or ten to the ten
times the mass of the Sun which was like
it's just a lot don't quote me on the
actual number but it's pretty yeah
pretty much pretty big yeah it's a
pretty big black hole have you seen
interstellar it's a long film but it's a
good one
so if you're ready for it yeah oh yeah
I'll watch it one day it's just it's
always some tiny little plane screens no
I feel it needs that yeah that's why I
say more gravity oh yes yeah frozen
frozen well because on planes you don't
cry any message to astrologers I'll try
not to be controversial go for the free
astrology but don't pay for it I
wouldn't invest money in someone making
stuff up just get a laser yeah I get
laser instead go to their museum that's
way more fun I challenge you to around
to everyone else in this series you're
number one consciousness okay Wow left
field number two metallicity how
chemically complex a star is a metal for
an astronomer is anything that is not
hydrogen or helium and number three The
Adventures of Tintin let's do this
y'all watch me flow I got the urge gonna
get Belgium like my name's hurt going
over there yeah I see you
Tintin ginger quit dog me Lou even
though on the TV they show me they
change the name from me Lou to snow we
lots of people get very angry because
Tintin they don't just understand he he
had the one set in the Congo kind of
racist people like oh no need to take it
back redo illustrations it got the spawn
of the Belgian nation they were like oh
no we are so proud we like to go Tintin
out in the crowd
Tintin ii-era try and separate his name
is Tintin double metal yes mate and that
is why the double metal do Pierre City I
talk about yes
the metallicity yeah you might think
it's complex by far but it's the complex
construction of inside a star your what
are they made of
I say again anything that's not hydrogen
and helium you can just say oh it's got
a lot of metals inside yes some copper
maybe all the other ones going from the
periodic I see them I flow so melodic
how much is the star I'll say again is
it metal like Metallica or Iron Maiden
does it wear a can of dog collar looking
like an old kind of aging rocker going
down to the scholar that's in London a
metal venue concerts they've held them
I'm sorry I cannot define more for you
about the metal compounds that burn
through the stars and say that one is
more metal than this does that one likes
Girls Aloud this one that kiss they are
more metal than most metal band I just
met their claim yet toss it outta hand
fact like the atom from different stars
in the hand on the right and then the
left are different I just bring it right
back
the last thing it's like a plan of
attack I think therefore I am
in maja a quote latin translate like I'm
Descartes but consciousness I really
must confess I feel conscious when I
wake up under duress the alarm clock
goes off and I feel I'm prodded from my
wake am like oh I gotta do a job get up
and get conscious get my brain working
I'd go learn about laser this to Zhirkov
to get the things going into my brain am
i conscious or am i just in saying i
don't know i can pinch my skin and feel
a ripple like a gravitational wave Oh in
the middle of space-time stretching it
other way consciousness is the latest
craze everybody's like am i living in
the matrix is that bad a conspiracy to
say this will people come along take me
in the black car and say consciousness
reaches has gone too far
no you're just a brain in a test tube
you're like a jellyfish you ain't got no
brain dude they be like no CIA resistant
I'm like a jellyfish no central nervous
system thank you oh yeah he's the most
famous Belgian and then any any other
thousand